alright so I'm Trent olyphant those of
you who came to this class thinking
you're going to hear Travis olyphant I'm
not Travis he is he is my brother
hopefully I can be as informative as he
is I do actually worked for his company
continuum and I'm a developer with
continuum and we've been I've been
working on a project in a in a fairly
large enterprise situation as a concern
a consulting project and so I this is
about how we use jingo specifically in
the data pipeline to help solve some
problems that are actually unique to the
enterprise okay I mean when I hear
enterprise data I think you know huge
data sets and big things like that and
you know oftentimes it's you think it's
going to look like this you know you've
got this one central data store and you
have some simple process you go through
and get some clear results out of it
that's that's the promise right of a big
data that's that's what that's what
everyone talks about but the reality
isn't even this clean where you've got
lots of different business centers that
all have to consolidate the data and you
have all the extra stuff and you then
you have to a bunch of complex processes
to get some results that may or may not
be clear okay so that's part of the
problem is just you've got the data
coming from so many different sources
and it's so it's going to be aggregated
and you know the problem with
aggregation is that how do you know that
you aggregate it on the correct
parameters had any other to that it's
been aggregated / up correctly you have
multiple business centers multiple
places they're coming from and all those
are different sizes and they all have
different data okay so sure you may be
wanting to gather this all into a single
place but it but unless but but if it's
different data you got to make sure that
it all has some common thing to some
commonalities between them in order to
be able to match them up and even within
a given business center all right you're
going to have multiple data sources with
multiple processes and then you have
your own
sets of results and then plus you just
you just need to send that on upstream
to the corporate okay so that's just a
kind of a general problem that an
enterprise has and but in the business
center you're going to have your own
reporting needs you didn't need to feed
it upstream and plus you've got a
smaller team and smaller budgets and
often times smaller data when with
enterprise IT departments often they
have policies that are trying to do you
know for everybody they've got solutions
that are supposed to be for everybody
and so that makes it often difficult for
smaller data teams you know in a
business center that they're just trying
to do their data reporting anyone hear
it work on a small data team inside of a
larger inside of a larger enterprise
okay yeah it's it's very very common
that there's a need for data scientists
in there and unfortunately sometimes
that supports not there the tools aren't
there corporations and enterprises are
recognizing this and so while it's been
slow in coming it's still not fully
there open source has become an option
okay there's and there's there's
actually a lot of good reasons for hope
for enterprises to adopt and allow open
source technologies in there within the
organization first of all there's cost I
mean it's that that's it that's all we
often a huge factor but it also has
become easier to use and I know that
when it went to first started off I've
I've been working with open source for
20 years now and it was painful to do
things in the beginning had you had to
roll your own and that's that's still
some of the disadvantages of
distribution and installation how do you
how do you get all of those things and
the support especially in an enterprise
level is problematic because while one
of the advantages of open sources you
have the
extremely broad community with all this
information you've got github you can
share you can you know solutions are
shared stack overflow if you have I mean
that's become the go-to source for me
anyway if I have a question I'm going to
stack overflow and see if anyone else
has had this similar problem and now
with anaconda org as well there's
different places to share the solutions
with each other unfortunately in the
enterprise some of those solutions can't
ever get out and so they're not
shareable you have proprietary data
you've got you've got you know
non-disclosure agreements all sorts of
things that you're working on and so and
so the sharing doesn't happen and in
fact it often doesn't even happen within
the enterprise so someone may have done
it on another team but when we're
talking to you know an organization that
has over a hundred thousand employees it
doesn't matter that someone has already
done this somewhere else if you don't
know about it you're going to have to
just redo it ok so you so those are some
of the problems that we face in in
working with open source now I mean
there are solutions around it in
anaconda Enterprise this yes this is a
small shameless plug for anaconda
enterprise that helps solve some of
those problems you can have a central
repository that is controllable by the
court you know by the corporate or the
enterprise IT staff but it allows for
easy package deployment collaboration as
well as support and and a big thing is
the indemnification that that seems to
concern a lot of managers they don't
care as much about the technical
superiority it's well who who's going to
answer for a problem that comes up okay
so we we chose we chose to use Django as
part of the solution oh this is just a
part of a solution and this is not a
tutorial about about about setting up a
django website this is specifically how
we used Django to solve some of the
problems that are inherent in
in in corporations who in here is not
familiar with Django to some extent so
everyone ahead okay so so what Django is
for those that may not know and and I'd
suggest that you go to django project
com they've got excellent documentation
but it's a web framework and it's
written in Python and it follows the
model view template model which most web
frameworks ruby-on-rails can't think of
any off the top of my head right now
they call it a Model View controller or
model controller view or model view
controller it's the same thing Django
just uses a different a different
terminology for it but it's called a
model view template and now you're
thinking okay we're not building a
website here mrs. this is data tools so
why why are you using this why are you
using a web framework in the first place
and the challenge or the part of the
reason is is that that provides an easy
wave to share the data and so they're
not just passing things around okay it
has a built-in web server so it makes it
it makes it really easy to create user
interfaces now everything I'm talking
I'm here I'm gonna give some examples
and some actual code of what we did but
all of what I'm sharing relies on
version 1.8 or higher okay which is
which is a pretty newer version so
they've made some they made some changes
recently so if you if you have older
versions some of this code may not work
for you or you have to do it just
differently you can probably make it
work but the but the syntax maybe may
have changed so why do we why go with
Django there since there are a lot of
these other types of options out there
it was easy install and setup has
built-in ORM built-in authentication
built in admin interface I mean so
basically one of the main reasons was it
had a lot of stuff already in the
package we didn't have to try to cobble
it together okay it's just it was it was
was just install and go and another big
reason is the talent pool okay and I
will get to that here a little bit more
now as far as easy install and setup
this this honestly is how easy it is to
get a jangle project going you just
can't install Django you can also pip
install because it's all in pure python
it's it's it's really quite easy to set
up and then you create a project and it
has a built-in development web server
now right there in the documentation and
in it says don't use this web server for
any production and that's that that is a
good idea but but it makes it really
easy for development purposes then you
just you just run the server you managed
up high run server so it's easily
installed and setup that's to get the
server running of course you have to get
your site up and you have to get all of
your code written it won't do that for
you but then the the jingle are 0 RM
anyone not know what oor M stands for
its object relational map okay because
most of our data is going to be in at
eight and in a tabular format oftentimes
in a sequel database okay if that's the
most common is a sequel database and
that's what an ORM generally does you
can connect to other system no sequel
and just had but it basically converts
from a relational type database into an
object model which programmers like to
program a little more in objects makes a
little bit easier to to write code for
than having to write all of the sequel
statements okay so also Jenga will
handle the DB management for you so it
can create your tables it can create it
can create your indexes it has it has
all that code to create that you work
with the objects and properties not with
the sequel directly but if you need to
so you have some esoteric join that you
need to do on multiple tables and sub
sub queries you can still do that you
can connect
directly to the to the database in fact
one of the examples i'll be showing we
we do bypass the ORM layer and go
directly to the database to just run the
run a sequel statement is that that
comes built in and if it also got
built-in authentication so it man it can
manage users for you and groups and
session yes it has built-in session
management so when someone logs in they
can you don't have to be checking every
single every single time so they've got
all of that already taken care if we
didn't have to build it ourselves didn't
have to run it in and they have some
basic permissions where which users can
can do what things and then it has a
really really easy to use admin
interface it's called admin but
basically it sits in it you can look at
the actual data itself okay look at the
tables it's it's not super featured like
a sequel you know it a sequel tool a
toad or or even a command-line sequel
you can't you can't run sequel
statements from the admin interface but
if you're looking at the data and you
just need to maybe change something
really quickly from the user interface
you can you can go into that and easily
change the data which allows for basic
data entry and editing okay again this
is this is basic but its built-in it's
real it's it's very simple to plug into
and you don't have to build it to build
it yourself and then another thing that
that isn't as much of a consideration in
an open source project necessarily but
is definitely a huge consideration in an
enterprise is the talent pool in other
words what is the availability of
someone to replace you I know that we
don't like to think about that it's like
well why would you ever want to replace
me
um they probably don't but you may want
to leave ok and then so if you've built
this esoteric solution that you've that
no one else can come in and do you've
created a little bit of Technology debt
want to thank Jim kitchen for that for
that word right there you've created a
cost there for someone else to come
along and try to understand it and so
sure people may not want to use a tool
like jangle because it has so much in it
that's all I don't need that that's just
extra why can't I just do my own thing
roll my own well you need to be replaced
so it's often good to maybe even trade
off some features especially an
enterprise to trade off some features
for a better community and django has a
very large and active community they
have conferences lots of developers
building plugins and so therefore it's
there's a lot of available people to
help on the projects I used to be very
against frameworks in general until I
started working in enterprise and seeing
how important that commonality is in
reproducibility okay so course and you
can always ask questions well what about
this package or that package sequel
alchemy flask and turbo gears I'm even
even within the Python framework web
framework community you've got all of
those available those are all great
packages we just happen to have decided
on django and there's some specific
reasons that we did versus Flass versus
django and part of it was the more
all-inclusive I've only barely started
looking at turbo gears it looks really
really interesting but we obviously
wants you to start with something
especially enterprise and then you've
got a solution working you don't just go
changing it just to change it so all
right I'm going to tell you a little bit
about the specifics of our project just
in some general terms so we had some
requirements basically what it was is
that we have we're forecasting doing
some financial forecasting
it's very common a project in an
enterprise and so we weren't we weren't
actually doing the modeling ourselves
they have they have a special team to to
do the forecasting what we were brought
in to do is to automate that to automate
the process of doing these forecasts it
was a very very heavy complex process
that they wanted to to make easier and
part of that requirement was to have a
simple user interface and they need to
have the ability to regularly update the
data so this is this this is forecasting
it needs to happen on a continual basis
and so people need to say okay I need to
upload new data now how do i need to get
my new data I need to have that and
because of the nature of of who was
working with this information is that we
had to integrate with Excel now I put
integration in quotes there because it's
not a direct integration it's just that
we had to take that into consideration
in the workflow it's not that we're
trying to control this from Excel or
control Excel directly from this so it's
not that tight integration it's a very
loose integration but i would i would
say that i would argue that excel is
probably the most widely used data tool
in the world okay know a lot of data
scientists say well that's not a data
tool well it is it's a data tool and and
non-programmers non data scientists use
it extensively and so that was an
important part of the requirement is
that we were able to somehow tie into
the Excel usage okay so are the teams
that we had for this we had four
different groups that are modeling we
had our modelers the modeling group we
had our finance group we had our data
group and we had been the development
group so I was part of the development
group and big part of it was automating
the actual models that were being
created converting them into into Python
they actually built the models in Excel
and we could see how how untenable
that was for any kind of scalability or
usability but that's what that's how the
modelers and the finance team that's how
they were able to work together because
they're both very familiar with that
they also did some some testing and sass
in fact that that's these are some of
the tools that were used these sass and
oracle and teradata the actual data that
we worked on wasn't the was actually an
aggregation of millions of rows of of
transactional data that was stored in
teradata we were doing we were doing
work on on the aggregation of that and
so they would they would aggregate up to
Oracle and in SAS and so the modelers
and the finance they worked with SAS and
Excel to come up with with the model
itself and then we use the development
team figured out how to translate that
into Python a runnable Python code and
that's actually a whole another
interesting discussion is that how we
can't with some of the solutions that we
came up with that one but then there was
the data team and we were working most
directly with the data team because we
were trying to solve their pain all
right they because the the modeling
people would come to them and say hey we
need this we need this data here and
then they'd have to figure out this
process to get them the data they needed
and so a lot of what we did was was to
help the data team and then besides
those those four groups we also have
other outside influences you've got
corporate finance that has their needs
you've got corporate IT that you've got
to deal with because you have to make
sure you're complying with all the
policies provisioning of machines and
then we also had internal corporate
audit the internal corporate audit team
we had to work with and then regulations
you know even outside the company you've
got event laws and rules and things jet
to fly to deal with and if you're
dealing with any publicly traded company
regardless of whether they work with the
government or not just the fact they're
publicly traded they have to have there
are certain things that that are that
are regulated with
the data okay are we are talking about
the tools use just quickly some of the
environments that we had we we actually
had to have three separate servers
excuse me in retrospect we I think we
would have liked to have gone with four
servers just because of the nature of
what the production the uat the user
acceptance testing the production we had
no access to production whatsoever as
developers so it needed to be a complete
solution so user acceptance testing was
the closest that we we could ever get to
that and it would have been nice to be
able to fully replicate production on
uat and then us have two machines for
development and then integration or
preparation and we all have you know
everyone has their own work stations and
the workstations are just desktops or
laptops with a Windows 7 enterprise on
it but they're locked down okay you
can't you can't you can only do what's
approved by the company you can't you
can't just go and install anything we
wanted to now the servers that we had
working with we had Oracle servers and
we had Linux running Apache actually out
of a whole stack on that it's a specific
install we were very fortunate they they
had it because it takes months sometimes
to get a server provisioned to be able
to use by the time we got there they had
already been in that process for six or
seven months so we already had the
servers we didn't have to wait for them
to be provisioned so that's that's
something that oftentimes in open source
you don't have to think about is how do
we how do we deal with those with
waiting for the for the proper things
now a little bit about the data itself
as I said before it's aggregated from
Terra data and we were actually had a
very lative Lee small set of data when
with comparison to other two other teams
but we still live with that we had 115
different tables that we were working
with and each and and we would do a
forecasting run okay that's the that's
what they were doing and each run would
generate about 30 megabytes of data so
again we're not talking big data here
this is
all manageable even with on even on a
laptop I mean it's it's not big data
that so that wasn't the problem wasn't
this a problem of scale problem is a
problem it was a problem of operations
now each month the future data the ones
that they had they hit they had
forecasted would become real the next
month they'd say okay this is this now
realest lie to be able to update that
plus what if they wanted to create a new
scenario well let's suppose that this
variable does this instead or let's
suppose this one does that so they
wanted to be able to create new future
data sets as well new scenarios okay so
so some specific issues that that we can
go was solving the biggest one is data
governance and controls okay everything
that we I mean so much of what we do is
we always have to ask add to ask
ourselves the question what is this how
does this relate to the rules the
corporate rules the enterprise rules
regarding the data governance know who
is anyone not familiar what data
governance is even had not heard that
term before okay most of you probably
had to deal with it a big thing was that
people only certain people should be
able to have access to the data and we
had that we had to certify and verify
that that was the case and so and we we
had to go through there the corporate
single sign-on process okay and we had
to be able to have user level access
control and then validation to make sure
that the data fits within within the
guidelines other problems that we had
was was just sharing the data as i said
the court the finance and modeling team
they would just share excel files back
and forth well one of the problems is
that ok now I've got which version of
the of the file am I using I've made
modifications okay who changed that and
then on the database and you have you
have concerns about who has access to
what tables to be able to to modify
which data now when it comes when it
came time to actually implementing this
to production you've got we have
Limited machine access okay so on those
production and uat machines you have no
shell access at all in order to get
anything done with that you got a scent
you got it you got to give that to a
third-party install okay you've got to
go to you know fill out a ticket and
have corporate IT do that I see some
smiles out here because I can tell they
chance this is obviously a problem that
you guys are all are very familiar with
okay so we're going to go with the talk
about some specific things that we did
and these may or may not fit and help
you in your specific situation if there
are if there's maybe something that we
didn't cover in here we may have
actually solved it but I just didn't fit
it into the into our solutions and so
feel free to come and talk to me about
your about your specific problem and
we'll see if we can't if maybe I we
don't have some insight here okay so now
we're getting some details about how we
use Django who in here has actually ever
done at an application in Django has
anybody done at an application in Django
okay so you would be somewhat familiar
with kind of how the data flows you have
a request that comes in this is this is
the second line here you have a request
that comes in and goes through middle
some Middle where we'll talk a little
more about that does the URL resolution
and the view resolution in the template
and then you send back the response okay
that's great once you get to django but
on our system first we had an Apache
server ok which Apache integrates fairly
nicely with Django it's a little bit
more have more of a hassle than with
others but it's not that difficult to do
the biggest problem was though is that
we didn't actually get the actual HTTP
request from Apache because it had to go
through this SSO agent that sat on the
machine that's what verify you know that
so people would go and log in to the
they they'd use the sso authentication
and then that request would then be sent
to django okay
now it's a couple of solutions that I'm
going to talk about specifically are in
middleware so that that's why I put this
in here it's normally not shown in the
that's not enough it's there because
there's some built-in middleware but
when you're building a simple a simple
web application you don't always think
about the middleware and that's that's
actually a really good place to look so
so if what I done doesn't match any one
of your scenarios and you're thinking
about well how do I make this work
chances are it's going to be in the
middle where somewhere okay just because
of where it sits now middleware even
though I have it there before the URL
resolution it can actually go also
between the URL resolution and the view
resolution and there's also another
layer between the template resolution
and then there's actually five different
entry points for middleware within that
chain and that's all in the date and the
jangle documentation but so just just
think in your mind I can I solve this
that are doing some middleware entry
point and then the other thing about
this is is that your models now this is
where it's going to get little bit
confusing because the models are this is
Django models so which correspond to the
Django tables so the first thing was
integrating with with authentication so
yes we're using Django authentication
but we needed to customize it to
integrate with the sso so first of all
we just created a custom authentication
object or and then create a middleware
class and we updated our settings file
to be able to recognize that ok so the
settings dot pie file for those haven't
worked with Django that's that's where
you set into exactly what it sounds like
it's the settings for Django to know
what it's doing so those are the two
specific places that we change so here's
some code and all this code is actually
available up on a github repo that I've
got a link at the end so so if you want
to look at this code it's not runnable
in its current state because they're
just snippets all right but it's a good
it's a good a good model so this is just
how you generally do a custom
authentication you create a class and it
has
to have two functions in it authenticate
and get user okay that's that's the
that's the API for doing a custom
authentication now what we what we did
is we we created a specific
authentication that read the HTTP
headers okay that's what we ended up
passing in in the credentials so we
would get that we get the username and
then we'd say all right if you were
let's look and see if the users in there
if they're not if they weren't in there
we create we went ahead and created the
user now that worked in our specific
case because we knew that that people
would only be coming to it that had
access to the whole system so you know
we could very easily modify this to only
are you know to not add them as a new
user but take into a form that they can
be added as a user but this one we
wanted to make it as seamless as
possible so we just automatically added
them and then we set them up though as
inactive users so sure they were there
now entered in the system but they still
had to actually request permission from
the administrator to be able to have
access to specific parts of of the
system that was part of the governance
we need that it has to be this
multi-step process okay and then we
create a middleware class so this is
what's going to be called every time a
function comes in and it's a process
request all of the five entry points
start with process okay and then we just
set up the line in red on the bottom
that's that's our middleware so these
these functions will be run in order no
notice there's a bunch of them that that
start with Django those are built into
Django by default there there you don't
have to use them but all of them are
very are very powerful and I I'm not
unless you wanted to replace one of
those with one of your own leave them
there and go ahead and use them all
right and then and then the
authentication back end
we put our authentication first because
that's what we wanted it to check first
but we also included though the normal
the Django authentication so that if the
authentication of our back-end failed it
would then go on to check the next one
the way that it works is that Django
checks the very first authentication so
you could actually have three or four
different authentication backends if you
had different things you would just have
them listed here in the order you wanted
them to be attempted ok so then another
thing we did to help with development is
we would actually mock the integration
because you saw the the you know to get
something actually on the servers was
tricky but we needed to have that it to
know how I was going to work and so we
created a simple function that with the
yamo file we could we could fake we
could mock who was who was longing in
and then here's the code to get the
mocked headers and so we would we would
we replaced the headers are we added to
the headers rather and so here's the
here's the code itself that in the
middleware class we just updated the
middleware class to look and CEO is
there a standard ID that came in because
that was added by that SSO agent that
was in there that's how we got those
headers in there was it that was added
by the SSO agent and so it's like okay
that's already there all right then
don't then don't worry about it just
we're just going to Guinea we do what we
what we did in the in the normal class
otherwise our headers are now are mocked
headers okay and then it is just the
code for us to be able to switch quickly
between you know we just go into this
yam will file and so I replaced rent up
there with Bob and now all of a sudden
when I go to the to view the page it get
thinks I'm Bob okay all right so now
access control was an interesting thing
Django has built-in permissions but the
permissions in Django are at a model
level which correlates to the table
level well that's great if that's how if
that's how you're going to present your
data but
oftentimes our forms are across lots of
different you know lots of different
tables and so we created a UI
permissions which basically would be on
a view based or a page level so first we
had to create a custom content type and
a model manager as well as a custom
permission model that's based on the
permissions then we have to register it
and we add a decorator to the views okay
so it's a little bit more of a complex
process but you can see that each of
these pieces is actually very small so
with the the content type we simply it's
an entry in the database okay and in the
content types table Django content type
table and you can either do a direct in
the database or through the admin
interface create a custom permissions
manager that that calls it calls the
permission manager but then does a
filter on it okay because because the
the permission that we created here is
just a subclass of the built-in
permissions and the main reason we did
this we didn't have to do this but the
main reason we did this is that with a
hundred and fifteen tables and we only
have like maybe five different views
that people had to look at but they
would have to go search through all
those tables to find the right
permission so we wanted to have these in
its it just in its own set in the admin
interface okay and then we just add the
permission to the view using the
decorator ok so then another another
thing that we had was ok how do people
get access to the output files or to
even to the output in the database
because according to the controls they
couldn't actually many of the users
didn't have rights to the database so
they couldn't just go to a database and
write a query so that if they wanted to
get the data we had to provide an
interface from going to do that and many
of them wanted it in an excel file so we
would create the excel files that would
either email or down or be able to
download plus we would generate for
especially during development extra
debug information we store those on the
file system in CSV files and then plus
we have their log files and all of those
need to be accessible we were actually
kind of I was surprised anyway to find
that the log files have to be accessible
for audit purposes it makes sense when I
thought about it but I just hadn't
thought about it before okay so to
create the net excel file we used xls
writer and and then pandas so basically
we get we created pandas dataframe and
then wrote each query into its own tab
created an excel file I don't have the
code here it's just pretty
straightforward as far as X as far as
xls use the add table function into it
into a worksheet but the download file i
want to show you this because this this
actually is within django see that was
just a separate function to create the
Excel spreadsheet but we would call that
then from from Django to download the
file we use this is called file wrapper
and the reason we did that is because
file rapper action will provide chunked
it'll chunk it for you you don't have to
worry about your so with you know really
really like to worry about the data size
because everyone says well everything I
was reading about it when you're doing
this is oh no you don't want to you
don't want to have jingle serve your
large files well we kind of had to
because some of these files were created
on the fly you know they weren't they
weren't in a static location and so this
is just some code to do that and return
it it we just change the headers with
the response so that the browser knows
oh I'm getting a file and then so now
they have the ability to get an excel
file which is what they want to have but
we've controlled the data we've
controlled who was able to download that
access that excel file because of the
permissions that are set now the same is
true with in uploading data okay this
was if this was the one that they really
wanted to solve so we create a simple
form and then we had a rule they would
provide the users would provide the data
in an excel file we actually have on on
this on this site a downloadable file
that they can do that Excel template so
then they can just put the new
in there and go back and upload it in
here and we just and we provided that
because the tab names had to match the
table model names alright here's here's
the code itself this is very cleaned up
you know we did a lot of error checking
and now one thing to notice down here
the jingle rapper of the CX Oracle
connection so this this is this is here
where I do Ross equal because we wanted
to do execute many and the way Django
does execute many is a little bit odd
didn't really fit our needs okay and so
we wanted to run the just the raw
execute many have inserting into the
table but the CX Oracle connections
expects a slightly different format than
Django delivers it and Django wraps the
CX Oracle connection and so we had to
know we had to pretend that we the this
was Django created and Django creates it
by putting in that value holder there so
he couldn't just create it in the format
that CX Oracle wanted even though
ultimately that's what the tool that was
really putting it into the database we
we just had to do it that way so
that'sthat's what that note is in there
for okay talk a little bit about the
admin administration we're pretty much
we're pretty much out of time here so
there's a bunch more a bunch of other
things in here that the slides are
available when you go to the last slide
here oh sorry went too far okay so if
you have any questions I'm feel free to
talk to me afterwards I can I can share
with me but you can look at these slides
and the sample code that's in here is
all available on these on these points
here you've got on SlideShare I've got
the first time i've used slide sure i
didn't realize that it was going to take
the name of my presentation and turn it
into that long although you can't you
can't miss admit miss this one up with
any other presentation there so so thank
you very much
you